thank you
[Music]
everybody everybody
oh baby baby
[Music]
set you outside but you ain't that
outside worldwide hoodie with the mask
outside in case you forget foreign
[Music]
looking for something that lives inside
salvation
[Music]
foreign
thank you for joining me for this yearly
tradition for reasons that I cannot
recall I started doing a yearly video on
Martin Luther King Jr day just to kind
of check in and see where my flow was at
come down to Dupont Circle over here and
brave the foot traffic and it's always
an interesting challenge so thank you
for joining me for that I also want to
just give a big shout out to the Friends
of the channel big thanks to dark monk
fire Mecca flow fests flow toys juggling
calling higher Terra light toys and
Ultra POI for helping to make the videos
on this channel possible thank you very
very much for your support you can learn
more about all these companies and the
work that they're doing to support
floors like yourself by checking out the
links that I've got down in the
description of this video also big
thanks to the non-business Friends of
the channel That is laymanchinski and
Becca pekunen thank you both so very
much for your support from my work and
my mission uh thanks also because this
video would not be possible if it were
not for the very generous support of all
these nice people right here these are
my flow patrons over on patreon and they
and the people who sit down in the
description helps to make this video and
all the videos on this channel possible
thank you so very much each and every
one of you and if you're out there
watching are not currently supporters
and you would like to become supporters
you can do that by heading on over to
patreon.com directs Factor POI where you
can get access to a whole host of
awesome rewards so go check that out
please and thank you
and if you would like to check out other
flow videos I've done over the years
including other videos that I've done on
MLK day I will go ahead and leave links
to all those in a playlist down in the
description as well as up on screen if
you are watching on YouTube also the
YouTube algorithm thinks that you might
like this top video so go check that out
as well thanks so much for watching make
sure to get outside and flow today and
I'll see you with a new video very soon
peace